launch someone out of the cannon in vr
no
dude it's like a bug's life
two years ago we made a video where we
put a gopro in this little arrow and put
it in a cannon and fired it several
hundred feet into the air
it was a really cool experiment but
we've never really had a need to do it
again until that is this year where we
start getting some really cool 360
cameras so today i'm going to design a
thing to put a 360 camera into a canon
and fire it into the sky and see what
kind of cool images we can get yo if we
get good 360 footage can we launch
someone out of the canon in vr
i'm serious like is there a way to like
be in the cannon with a oculus or
something yeah like that's the best idea
we should definitely do that assuming
the footage works we could totally throw
it into like any vr headset put you in
hit play and watch you go
dude
so really it's quarter a crew in a
cannon we have to make this work because
i want to be shot out of the cabin so
the basis of this whole video will be
based around this giant air cannon all
the air that was compressed in here goes
shooting out through this barrel and
anything that was in here gets shot out
of it at a really high speed here we
have the insta360 one x it's the newest
camera from insta360 even though this
thing fits
it fits it's just it doesn't fit enough
so we have about one millimeter on
either side of this thing that we are 3d
printing i have to be able to design a
housing that is that thick yeah this is
supposed to stop it from breaking
why not just use a slightly older camera
still great we filmed that whole
freaking arrow video with this thing so
how much clearance does that buy you i
it gives me so much more room to
actually design a case around it
that's a lot of force like i mean you
remember what happened with the gopro
oh baby that one's so high
we killed the gopro what makes you think
that's gonna survive no offense to
insta360 but like if they're not if we
can break a gopro session which are like
freaking diamonds in terms of toughness
i don't know if little insta360 is gonna
make it i'm gonna get to the drawing
board so i can actually start designing
something to hold this thing because
look at this this isn't this isn't gonna
work
you got this okay i think i have a
design i'm actually pretty happy about
this i've been getting better at using
fusion 360 to model things let's hit
print i've got all three of these pieces
on the same plate printing at the same
time by the end of it i'll be able to
clean it all up and stick it together
it'll be a finished product the idea was
to mimic the gopro mortar but this only
has three fins and apparently it's more
stable if you have four fins the problem
i ended up quickly running into is that
in order to transform this area into
something that can fit this while also
still having a long enough tail to keep
it stable it quickly outgrew the bounds
of our 3d printing volume so i had to
split it into different parts one that
will hold the camera and then another to
fit the tail so the thing about 3d
printing is that it lays down a sheet of
plastic one slice at a time long ways
the plastic is fairly strong but layer
by layer you're relying on the adhesion
between each of those slices and that's
less strong so instead i decided to
print it on its side print up like that
that way the plastic goes through the
entire length of the thin parts of the
design keeping it nice and strong and i
think it worked i think it worked get
this out of here get them time lapse
cameras out of here whoa
chances are i'll probably have to do a
lot of sanding to get things to fit but
i'm happy about this
it fits i'm actually really proud of
this little design i managed to make
multiple pieces to make a single part
[Music]
and now
final piece this is the 3d model i was
showing you yesterday and now it's a
real physical thing in your hands that's
shirts guys
oh god why you always copying you wore
my shirt that's my face
get out of here
i'm always up to something now
oh
like a glove look at that look at how
perfectly that fits so it fits really
nicely on the one side but the other
side it has gaps and that's so that it
can actually be removed this screw here
is going to go in through the bottom
like this and then it's supposed it's
supposed to
it's supposed to come out the bottom
check that out so now i've got the
little screw in there that should be
able to mount to the camera it fits
perfectly oh and speaking of which i
just realized we have to figure out some
way to launch this out of the cannon if
we just put this in the cannon right now
all the air is going to go around it and
it's not even going to leave the cannon
so you need some sort of stuffer yeah
what do you call like the the stuffers
they used in muskets back in the day
freaking musket stuffer yeah we need
some sort of musket stuffer i'll
probably 3d print a 50 millimeter wide
circle but the moment the disc actually
leaves the cannon it flies away it's
just meant to push but not actually fly
with the arrow here i think this thing
is ready to be fired out of a cannon
tomorrow let's go to the park tomorrow
morning cue tomorrow
and we're here hopefully this works
yeah we're here today at whittier park
to shoot a camera out of a cannon again
that's why i'm playing this beat and i'm
singing this song because ren's gonna
have some real good fun he's gonna put
on a helmet or maybe he won't he's gonna
try to catch it in the field maybe he
won't he's gonna ride his one wheel
he'll definitely will and now we're
gonna go and shoot this camera we have
one camera per shot meaning that we only
have enough air to fire this thing twice
and probably the camera's gonna break on
each one meaning one camera one shot i
give it a 50 50 chance which basically
just means i don't know if it'll break
or not i'll hit record
is the lens clean
it well he went to this finger so it's
definitely clean now
tamper that didn't go as planned
there you go nice
oh i love that sound all right you're
good you're right wait a minute
i'm gonna open this one up first and
then you take that off you rolled on it
right yeah i rolled on it ready you go
yep
ready this is the big moment oh my god
no helmet ready three two one
oh
that was spinning
that went so far
so i know the cap landed somewhere over
here niko's going after the actual thing
it like spun like crazy when it left
oh i found it and it's still recording
oh it totally did break though dude look
at that yeah so it just snapped the tail
off
but that's why i printed two tails well
assuming it actually was able to
stabilize that it should be fine
[Music]
it works it works
it worked it worked
there's a moment where like it doesn't
stabilize and it locks and then it just
clicked dude
oh my god
so much more stable looking than the
gopro
that is so cool
oh my god it worked can we shoot
straight up next time i think we can do
that
all right i'm gonna shoot it from right
here three two one
dude caught it
[Music]
not bad oh yeah
yeah we're back wren's on a phone call
potentially setting up a tedx talk but
while he's doing that we got fresh air
all right let's go right up when jake's
ready
ready
three two
one
cool
it's way up there oh my god it's so high
boom oh it's done
that's dead it's done
it absolutely demolished the prince
oh my gosh
it's in pieces maybe the camera's okay
so much higher than i thought maybe the
camera's okay
oh it is in there dude it's not budging
sword in the
what happened
i i take it from your reaction it didn't
go well
close your eyes are there pieces no
there are pieces
what happened remember when calvin drops
his dad's binoculars and they turn into
dust
oh my god
wait
did this happen from impact yeah it was
buried in the ground it went like two to
three times higher than the gopro did
we're back from the field the third shot
that went really high up hit the ground
so hard it actually popped the sd card
out of the 360 camera that camera was
still rolling when that card popped out
which meant that the file was basically
corrupted i tried recovering it i
couldn't do it so we did push this whole
experiment to the max to the point that
it shattered the entire case but
fortunately we have a couple good clips
and i've assembled that into a 360 video
that we can watch today in vr so i'm
currently inside the canon and it looks
like i'm in a freaking missile silo
all right shot one let's see how this
goes okay
and whoa actually no joke
no joke that was okay the crash landing
was a little disorienting but
[Music]
okay that one was way freakier than the
first one are you looking up the missile
silo yes i'm in like a huge missile silo
like a little cannonball goodbye cruel
world
and crash
this is really cool here's the straight
up one here
oh oh shoot no need go catch me
i'm safe in the towel of nico
oh
no
i'm like a dude it's like a bug's life
whoa
yeah there you go there you go what is
that little thing
yeah that kind of made my stomach go
when you look straight down that speed
[Music]
there's a link in the description to an
unlisted version of that 360 video so
you can experience what it's like to be
launched from a camera as well if you
have a vr headset or google cardboard
whatever mobile 360 viewing platform of
your choice
yeah
hey we're here with another episode of
the corridor crew to shoot off a video
for node wait nodes right hey guys nico
from node here i am the
n the o is brand on the d is obviously
sam
and the e is
[Laughter]